[Musique]
les chevaux sont des animaux fascinants
qui ont une longue histoire
d'interaction avec l'être humain ici au
cadre noir ils l'ont bien compris depuis
longtemps ils étudient leur anatomie
leur évolution leur comportement les
soins des chevaux demandent beaucoup
d'applications notamment grâce à leur
fidèle compagnon le palefrenier et le
maréchal-ferrant Olivier et Ivan vont
m'expliquer pourquoi il est important de
prendre soin de ses animaux et d'assurer
leur bien-être bon je vais me faire un
petit kiffe franchement je suis désolé
j'ai vu les trucs à la Fashion Week ça
se passe
[Musique]
que le mannequin de la Fashion Week
n'est pas content il ne sourit pas
vivons comment ça va bonjour c'est qui
qui nous amène là c'est comment son
prénom alors ça c'est vif du Louvet
alors ici on est où là on est dans ton
entre là on est dans la forge de l'école
et c'est là où tous les chevaux de
l'école reviennent régulièrement toutes
les six semaines pour le ferrage
pourquoi tu vas commencer là alors
l'état numéro 1 il faut relever les
rivets pour pouvoir retirer plus
facilement le faire voilà maintenant on
va pouvoir le déférer ça fait partie des
soins et c'est quand même un confort
pour le cheval ça bien sûr là c'est la
seule la seule la fourchette là qui est
en V là ici on a les talons et ça c'est
toute la paroisse c'est une matière
osseuse ça c'est de la kératine comme
nos ongles en fait en tout cas tu as
l'oeil parce qu'il y a des trucs que tu
enlèves moi ça fait partie d'un atomie
du cheval en fait pas du tout quoi on a
pas de d'appareillage de mesure tout se
fait à l'oeil
[Musique]
il est où Camille
j'arrête parce que franchement on voit
rien du tout
là il est chaud
donc tout est à l'oeil quoi c'est dingue
j'ai une mémoire visuelle du pied et je
redonne la même tournure au fer en fait
l'intelligence artificielle là bim tu
pourras jamais remplacer les
maréchal-ferrant fais-moi sa banane les
algorithmes
donc en fait les chevaux vous êtes quand
même des mutants quoi 1000 degrés sur le
pied et tu mâchouille
fouie
toujours des mutants tu leur enfonces un
clou dans les pieds
rien du tout ah ben écoute je te laisse
finaliser
les chevaux je cherche Olivier je suis à
la recherche d'Olivier le palefrenier ok
je te laisse manger pas de problème
l'olivier oui bonjour Olivier toi qui
est palefrenier sur m'explique un petit
peu quel est ton rôle mon rôle c'est de
prendre soin des chevaux des écuries des
écuries soient propres que les chevaux
soient propres et en forme qui puisse
ainsi travailler correctement tu fais
des tresses alors oui il faut qu'ils
aient la queue nouée dans l'arnachement
afin de pouvoir évoluer sans gêner le
cavalier et sans se gêner-lui
ça va être juste
en noir et Olivier se téléporte des fois
c'est à dire que tu le suivi il est
devant toi et il est là la sellerie
d'honneur on est déjà reparti là
et il part oui pour les matinales du
Cadre Noir de sodium eBay c'est nous
honore ce matin ok c'est fini pour le
mettre à chevalier va arriver
[Musique]